[Musica]
[Applauso]
in un mondo che è un mondo urbano
sebbene le città occupino meno del 3 per
cento della superficie del pianeta le
persone la gente l'uomo vive e si sposta
prevalentemente nelle città e la
tendenza è quella di ribadire tale
scelta
un atteggiamento culturale che ha creato
una inevitabile crescita e varietà per
numero e dimensione specchio di
differenti stili di vita
protagonista del mio intervento è il
contesto costruito che ospita la vita
dell'uomo più sinteticamente definibile
con il concetto di città non può
esistere una corretta pianificazione del
mondo e della realtà senza un costante
confronto con la storia dei luoghi e
delle culture e arresto nathan rogers
grande architetto e critico
d'architettura usava ripetere che
bisogna conoscere la storia per poterla
dimenticare e poter essere se stessi
infatti un popolo senza memoria è
destinato a ripetere errori già commessi
un confronto con il passato favorisce il
vissuto della contemporaneità sia in
caso di permanenza e continuità con la
storia si è che l'azione manifesti
carattere di temporaneità e
discontinuità con essa in questo dialogo
tra passato e presente risiede il valore
sequenziale ed evolutivo della realtà in
cui viviamo
l'eterogeneità degli assetti urbani
esistenti esibisce contesti dove una
vera e propria storia non è ancora stata
scritta
altri al contrario che presentano
contesti fortemente caratterizzati dalla
presenza di un vissuto urbano lo
sappiamo la città è ovunque
è vero vivremo in megalopoli da oggi al
2050 si prevede che la popolazione oggi
di 6.7 punto 6 miliardi di
i tanti crescerà fino a 10 miliardi di
persone nonché oggi il 54 per cento del
totale della popolazione vive in città
questa percentuale nel 2050 salirà e
raggiungerà il 70 per cento ma già
domani nel 2030 le megalopoli cioè le
città con sofia con un numero superiore
a 10 miliardi di persone saranno oltre
ciò nonostante nei paesi della comunità
europea quasi due terzi della
popolazione vive oggi in centri urbani
di piccole e medie dimensioni
non vi è dubbio l'italia appartiene a
questo paradigma per noi la storia è
contemporaneamente un debito e un enorme
ereditata proteggere e valorizzare la
città europea vive una stagione sempre
dinamica mai statica essa si ampia si
modifica costantemente nel tempo aprendo
si è continuamente in modo diffuso
modificando il nostro comportamento che
ha un comportamento urbano la città
al contrario del passato non è più
misurabile con variabili quali la
densità la continuità la varietà la
realtà urbane oggi è discontinua
notevoli differenze di densità abitativa
difficile stabilire dove inizia la
campagna e dove finisce la città
i nuovi ingredienti legati al concetto
di tempo libero d epoca postmoderna
cambiano e modificano gli assetti delle
abitudini i contesti di tradizione
storica però si esibiscono sviluppo e
concentrazione un fenomeno che negli
stati uniti viene chiamato shrink in
aumento di massa e riduzione del peso
corporeo delle nostre città
il tema quindi al confronto con
l'esistente il di amiche e con la pro
città costruita il nuovo esiste e ha un
senso anche là dove l'uomo ha già
operato azioni di trasformazione
soprattutto il contesto europeo non
esigere il disegno di una nuova città
piuttosto è necessario individuare
strategie di sviluppo conformi alla
realtà esistente tale concetto oggi
si definisce con il nome di
rigenerazione urbana nella realtà
italiana il tema è quello di rigenerare
pezzi frammenti di città possessori di
un disegno storico che hanno perduto
a fronte della modificazione delle
popolazione rigenerare infatti significa
confrontarsi con le nuove esigenze della
contemporaneità
all'interno dei tessuti storici e
facendo aderire a nuove forme le
popolazioni urbani che sono tutte
portatrici di altre esigenze costruire
quindi nell'esistente e sull'esistente
questa è la domanda che è stata posta la
nostra generazione ma alcune esperienze
costruite saranno il manifesto materiale
di questa mia breve riflessione teorica
scrive paolo portoghesi
la teoria è quella che l'architettura
ogni architettura nasce da altre
architetture da una convergenza non
fortuita fra serie di precedenti che si
combinano attraverso l'immaginazione di
un processo che coinvolge la solitudine
del pensiero e la coralità della memoria
collettiva
la sopravvivenza del paesaggio italiano
mi sto portando a collodi si accredita
attraverso l'ascolto della cultura dei
luoghi e il rifiuto di uno sviluppo
omologato proprio nelle differenze si
esprime la bellezza la continuità
l'armonia ogni contesto urbano e oggi
portatore di stratificazioni e può così
aggettivare si in quanto storico il
progetto contemporaneo persegue quel
processo di storicizzazione nel binomio
continuità discontinuità assonanza
dissonanza si collo la l'epicentro
dell'importanza tra il dialogo con le
preesistenze ambientali
noi dobbiamo vivere la città dobbiamo
conservarle valorizzarla
il meglio del passato e del vissuto di
oggi dobbiamo tradurlo per il domani
la vita lo sappiamo è somma di
esperienze anche la città è soprattutto
un condensato di esperienze una
bellissima canzone di francesco de
gregori recita la storia siamo noi la
storia e perciò non sono gli edifici o
meglio non sono solo gli edifici o gli
spazi
che si formano la storia è costituita
dagli uomini che la vivono gli abitano
la interpretano e quindi il rapporto
dialettico tra memoria e contemporaneità
in ogni disciplina è la sintesi
dell'ambiguità e delle difficoltà che
tutti noi oggi stiamo attraversando la
relazione tra le espressioni della
contemporaneità e le istanze e tracce
del passato coinvolgono un azione
pratica e costruttiva spesso i fenomeni
quelli della modernità hanno indebolito
mortificato infierito sulle nostre città
e soprattutto sull'ambiente è
inconcepibile in italia un idea di
architettura estranea ai concetti di
memoria e di identità anche in relazione
alle attuali problematiche di natura
ambientale
il processo è sempre un processo
analitico di sintesi che vede il
progetto come strumento di analisi
sarebbe inadeguato oggi riproporre la
frase che frank lloyd wright grande
architetto del guggenheim di new york
rivolse a libri video uno storico
dicendo tutti e due
ci occupiamo di storia ma lei la scrive
io la faccio l'azione critica la
coscienza del passato la consapevolezza
del presente ma soprattutto la
propensione al futuro sono fattori
strategici e sinergici di una
divulgazione del sapere ogni epoca deve
avere la forza di rappresentare se
stessa di lasciare le tracce attraverso
il costruito di se stesse nel suo
pensiero della sua filosofia di vita
bisogna contrastare quindi una
concezione del passato come fenomeno
chiuso incluso distinto dal presente
tramite una fattura e rimovibile ecco
allora che le nuove generazioni
mi rivolgo a loro tendono a creare una
frattura per loro esiste un obsoleto
passato e una contemporaneità evoluta
i ragazzi lo sappiamo posseggono tutti
un'elevata dotazione strumentale e
grandi capacità strumentali alla quale
però non fa seguito una adeguata
capacità critica contrasti ibridazioni
fusioni allegorie riferimenti sono tutti
aspetti che la matrice contemporanea
dell'architettura della città e legge a
processi legittimi e dico io auspicabile
la risata questo inerente la connessione
logica quindi tra architettura
contemporanea e contesti storici
riassume la quotidianità del rapporto
che definiamo antico nuovo e nel
concetto di continuità storica il
termine funzionale semantico e
tecnologico che rappresenta l'invarianza
ecco allora il paradigma mio di oggi
l'architettura costituisce un barometro
di un'epoca e la città consolidata e il
teatro di confronto di queste epoche non
esiste un'unica strada da ripercorrere
in futuro bensì molteplici sono gli
approcci contrastanti e complementari
l'uomo nasce costruttore e modificatore
del luogo che ha scelto come habitat un
bambino lo sappiamo lasciato il solo
sulla spiaggia sfoga la sua innata e
istintiva capacità di costruire
l'istinto del costruttore è nato
nell'istinto dell'uomo e quindi la
facoltà della mente di conservare
richiamare alla coscienza e ricordi e le
esperienze rappresenta sia un patrimonio
individuale ma soprattutto un patrimonio
collettivo della città
la memoria rappresenta il requisito
della cultura di un popolo della sua
nascita e soprattutto del suo sviluppo
ecco allora che si lavora sempre in
architettura in urbanistica nelle nostre
discipline per addizione sottrazione
cercando un colloquio con la
preesistenza all'interno del quale la
nuova progettualità delinea un tramite
tra passato e futuro non dimentichiamolo
noi costituiamo sempre un'entità di
passaggio tra un prima e un dopo
ecco allora che il tema riconducibile
all'antico e al nuovo o alla
conservazione all'innovazione come
affermava aldo rossi grande architetto
non può più essere al posto solo dal
punto di vista della relazione fra
vecchio e nuovo bensì dal punto di vista
della necessaria modificazione che si
procede ad un intervento
l'architettura è quindi tale quando
favorisce la sua fruibilità in linea con
il pensiero di un'intera collettività è
auspicabile ci pensavo ieri come fra
mille anni quando gli archeologi del
futuro troveranno le nostre rovine i
nostri edifici le nostre città riescano
con facilità adattare i nostri edifici e
tutto ciò che trovano per forma
materiali sistemi tecnologici e
costruttivi questo in quanto gli edifici
come gli uomini sono parti vive sono
parti pulsanti in continua e perenne
evoluzione la città
il mio è un ossimoro ne costituisce un
ambiente naturale ma usciamo dalla
metafora dell'architettura e come diceva
che dritti finiva l'architettura musica
pietrificata ampliano gli orizzonti ogni
azione umana soprattutto quella della
collettività prevede la storia come
motore dell'azione progettuale il
rapporto memoria contemporaneità è il
barometro degli elementi che compongono
la nostra società il lavoro il benessere
la salute i rapporti interpersonali e
gli stili di vita e con questi tutti i
rapporti che vogliamo che essi abbiano
con noi ogni trasformazione può essere
vissuta quando saldate in continuità con
la storia e non in opposizione qualche
giorno orsono il 6 ottobre il gruppo che
per governativo sul cambiamento
climatico ha redatto e approvato
purtroppo un allarmante
rapporto sancendo che la situazione del
riscaldamento del pianeta sta avendo un
andamento drasticamente peggiore di
quanto era stato preventivato ogni
azione quindi per il futuro e
riguardante la modificazione dei nostri
territori e delle nostre città non potrà
non partire dal mondo costruito da
questo paradigma di un ambiente da
preservare di risorse limitate e
all'interno di una logica di estrema
sostenibilità
ma all'interno di un paradigma che è
utile ribadire alcuni concetti che
ovviamente una disciplina quale è
l'architettura che è la sintesi di
valenze e variabili di natura
tecnologica e scientifica con quelle di
natura umanistica non può con certezza a
determinare ho sintetizzato alcuni
passaggi che potrebbero individuarsi
come regole della buona pianificazione e
regole per la crescita dei nostri
contesti da oggi e domani sono punti a
cui serviranno tre auspici e diciamo tre
azioni che anche nei nostri contesti più
tutti i giorni noi viviamo riusciremo ad
adattare la città storica
non c'è dubbio la storia ce lo dimostra
è la più resiliente di altre realtà in
quanto portatrice di già tante
trasformazioni è già abituata nel suo
dna
utilizzando il linguaggio medico tipico
della disciplina urbanistica possiede
già questo aspetto della sua perenne
trasformazione inoltre non dimentichiamo
le infrastrutture sono l'anima e anche
l'anello debole della nostra nazione
sono l'anello critico
viviamo in una realtà nelle quali non si
è investito in questo aspetto mi auguro
che l'infrastruttura e sia morale ma
soprattutto fisica costituisca il pro il
progresso nei prossimi anni
non c'è dubbio la città costituisce il
primario luogo e strumento democratico
questa parola importante
di inclusione e integrazione e
valorizzazione e la giornata di oggi ne
ha sicuramente la prova ed è la città
luogo dove confluiscono e vengono
valorizzate le differenze la città e
teatro e teatro non solo dentro al
teatro mai fuori negli spazi perché
accette accoglie e di coloro che hanno
deciso di lasciarlo a terra d'origine
per esigenze per volontà
noi abbiamo il dovere il compito di
accoglierli ma soprattutto la città è un
elemento didattico fare bene la città a
costruire bene alla città significa
abituare le persone ha un senso etico è
un senso civico che è andato perduto per
le nostre generazioni abitare una città
con forme significa essere educati a
diventare uomini
ecco allora in poche parole per i meri
semplici che non saranno sicuramente
innovativi ma che penso nelle nostre
realtà siano doverosi nei confronti
della nostra storia capire che la città
sono solo le persone non sono i
contenitori che li ospitano e che quindi
la società è alla base di una buona
costruzione fisica della città
il dialogo tra nuove l'antico come punto
di partenza e di confronto tra un prima
e un dopo
e sapere che la città va vissuta la
città sopravvive solo se vive quindi
apriamo i musei apriamo gli amici da
recuperare questa ne è una prova
penso che il futuro sia il recuperare
l'esistente perso ultimo messaggio vi
leggo al collega medico
la città è in corpo umano e operare oggi
con azioni di microchirurgia molto
mirate e puntuali penso sia lo sviluppo
del futuro
non vi è dubbio non demandiamo ad altri
questa nostra aspirazione questo sogno
il cittadino è il miglior medico della
città
vi ringrazio
[Applauso]